[Musique]
où
minuit
sur l'esplanade de la défense un soir de
mai dernier
les tours des entreprises du cac 40 sont
désertes
la nuit est noire couleur charbon
mais en sous sol une opération secrète
est sur le point de commencer
une quinzaine de jeunes militants écolos
ont tenté un coup de communication
spectaculaire
leur cible l'une des entreprises les
plus puissantes de france qui a besoin
d'un tee shirt
malika perron prépare cette opération
depuis trois semaines
ce soir l'action ça consiste en une
projection sur le siège d'edf est devant
au premier plan un message qui va être
edf pollution d'état et sur le bâtiment
va projeter edf stop charbon
le groupe s'élance s'entraîner
le commissariat n'est qu'à quelques
dizaines de mètres
[Musique]
qui étaient les amis là bas on est cinq
ans attention attention
et au bout de quelques minutes
le slogan apparaît en haut de la tour de
l'entreprise publique
un cliché impeccable il paraîtra dès
demain dans la presse pour attirer
l'attention sur une activité d'edf peu
connu les centrales à charbon une
énergie qui quand elle est consommée
brûlé aimait beaucoup de gaz à effet
serre qui sont responsables du
changement climatique et edf investit
massivement dans le charbon à l'étranger
c'est d'autant plus important que la
conférence des nations unies sur le
climat qui va se tenir à paris en
décembre 2015 est hébergé par par la
france or edf c'est une entreprise dans
lesquelles l'état est actionnaire et
donc la france doit vraiment prendre ses
responsabilités
le charbon c'est la nouvelle bête noire
des défenseurs de l'environnement
car tous les experts du climat le dise
cette source d'énergie bon marché est
responsable d'un désastre écologique
[Musique]
les émanations toxiques de certaines
centrales menace gravement la santé des
habitants
pourtant des entreprises françaises
investissent massivement dans ce
combustible salle des géants de
l'énergie comme edf et gdf suez 3
baptisé angie mais aussi des banques
françaises comme bnp paribas
dans le même temps ces entreprises se
façonne une image écolo à coups de
double page dans la presse
[Musique]
certaines sponsorise même la conférence
sur le climat
[Musique]
voilà un rallyman tandis qu'anne marie
blas
comment ces entreprises justifie t'elle
ce double discours
de la normandie à l'inde
en passant par l'italie et la pologne
nous avons percé l'écran de fumée qui
enveloppe ses investissements polluants
ses deux cheminées ce vote à des
kilomètres à la ronde
planté au beau milieu de la ville et du
port du havre elles font partie du
paysage depuis 47 ans
cette centrale à charbon est l'une des
deux dernières opéré par edf en france
mise aux normes européennes l'entreprise
publique la présente comme la vitrine
d'un charbon propre ce qui l'a incité à
nous ouvrir ses portes
le jour de la visite le numéro deux du
site inspectent les derniers chantiers
avec le nouveau directeur jacques
pradier
bonjour
devant notre caméra la visite commence
par les installations anti pollution
les travaux sont terminés on est en
phase d'essai ça avance bien
d'accord hélas le dépoussiéreur aider
flambant neuf il est prêt à fonctionner
prêt à fonctionner
en brûlant du charbon rejette plusieurs
types de polluants des particules fines
ap les poussières et des gaz dangereux
pour l'environnement et la santé comme
le monoxyde d'azoté ou le dioxyde de
soufre
pour les filtres et edf à construire de
gigantesques installations ces dernières
années comme cette usine de
désulfurisation à 120 millions d'euros
c'est une station convient également de
rénover de façon très importante pendant
le l'année qui vient de s'écouler et qui
nous permet de respecter les normes
environnementales qui entreront en
vigueur seulement en 2016
l'edf devance la réglementation au nom
de l'environnement c'est en tout cas le
message que ses dirigeants souhaitent
faire passer
en réalité le charbon émettent un pôle
man contre lequel aucun filtre les mises
en place le dioxyde de carbone ou co2 le
principal gaz à effet de serre là sur ce
site combien ça rejette on s'est alors
vu combien c'est difficile à dire parce
que chaque année ça ça change l'année
dernière on a un peu tourné puisque on
était sûr c'est important programme de 2
de rénovation de l'unité de production
selon ce rapport de la commission
européenne la centrale a émis plus de 2
millions 700 mille tonnes de carbone en
2013 le sixième site le plus polluant de
france
mais c'est surtout en dehors de
l'hexagone que l'entreprise publique
polluent
[Musique]
edf est très actif à l'étranger
elle possède ses centrales à charbon
dans le monde
[Musique]
et son plus grand parc se trouve en
pologne un pays qui est parvenu à
repousser l'application des normes
européennes
[Musique]
et l'immense et centenaire cent mille
gueules noires
les installations rouillé et décati en
silésie dans le sud de la pologne l'or
noir règne toujours en maître
[Musique]
les centrales à charbon fournissent 90%
de l'électricité du pays
alors plusieurs mois dans l'année les
villes de la région se couvre d'une
brume toxiques
la pollution atmosphérique causerait
5000 morts prématurées par an selon la
seule étude sanitaire précise
[Musique]
mais rares sont ceux qui osent remettre
en cause son exploitation
pour ce disque wave koutchma un policier
à la retraite
ça a commencé par un geste banal un
matin d'hiver
dès que j'ai ouvert la porte j'ai été
entouré par une brume salle se faisait
rentrer chez moi de la fumée de la suite
et des mauvaises odeurs aussi j'ai très
vite fermé la porte
après trente années passées dans la
police le commandant koutchma a décidé
de pourchasser un nouvel ennemi la
pollution il passe sa retraite à
déchiffrer le peu de rapport sur le
sujet il a découvert des niveaux
toxiques alarmant dans sa ville
voici des statistiques officielles
elle mesure l'état de l'air à rybnik et
il est déplorable
ce qui est indiqué en rouge ce sont les
dépassements de limites de particules
fines et on voit très clairement qu'il
n'y a eu que cinq jours en février où on
pouvait respirer de l'air qui
respectaient les normes
est l'un des coupables se trouverait à
quelques kilomètres de chez lui
l'unité thermoélectrique de rythmiques
la deuxième plus grosse centrale à
charbon de pologne
propriétaire des rendements
1775 km leurs trois fois plus que celle
du havre
odf l'a racheté en 2001 et c'est ainsi
implanté dans l'une des villes les plus
polluées d'europe
la centrale émet environ 780 tonnes de
particules dans l'air par an du plomb du
zinc du cadmium du qi vente ce sont des
substances très nocive pour la santé de
l'homme
l'unité rejette trop de gaz toxiques
trois fois plus de carbone co havre et
surtout quatre fois plus de soufre et
d'azoté
directive européenne oblige à fermer les
centrales qui ne sont pas aux normes
d'ici la fin de l'année mais en pologne
les opérateurs ont obtenu une dérogation
au nom de la sauvegarde de l'emploi
ils sont un délai de quatre ans pour
faire les travaux arythmique wire
en attendant les habitants de la région
continuent à souffrir de la pollution
edf a obtenu une dérogation pour
produire de l'électricité tout en
maintenant un niveau de pollution élevée
a répondu moi je le vois comme un permis
de polluer l'environnement c'est tout
simplement un scandale
la direction d'edf n'a pas donné suite à
notre demande d'interview mais nous a
affirmé avoir lancé un programme de
modernisation
nous n'avons pas obtenu une autorisation
d'aller le vérifier dans la centrale
nous tentons d'en créer en caméra
discrète
bonjour
nous sommes de la télévision française
france 2
mais peine perdue
ça n'est même pas possible que vous
descendiez ici pour une pareille je vais
prendre
l'entreprise publique est embarrassée
car le problème dépasse le cas de rybnik
son parc de centrales rejette plus de 60
millions de tonnes de co2 par an autant
que des pays entiers comme l'autriche ou
la colombie une information dérangeante
à quelques mois de la conférence sur le
climat
et cette vérité va éclater lors de
l'assemblée générale des actionnaires
d'edf au carrousel du louvre à paris
nous retrouvons malik apéro la militante
filmer quelques jours plus tôt à la
défense et pour assister à l'assemblée
générale il faut être actionnaire donc
elle a acheté une action edf nous
filmons discrètement
le mix énergétique
c'est un vrai grand défi on continue à
préparer l'avenir cette manière de
l'assemblée commence par un film
promotionnel en vente la responsabilité
environnementale de eu des changements
arrivent
ici on prépare le système électrique de
l'avenir pour assurer un bon service et
préparer la transition énergétique
trois minutes d'auto célébration jusqu'à
ce que la militante prennent le micro
deux
[Musique]
jours
vous n'êtes pas aborder le déplacement
vous savez cette année cruciale pour le
pire et pourtant vous avez toujours
l'intention d'investir dans de nouveaux
projets de centrales à charbon dans le
monde vous disent vouloir accélérer la
transition énergétique
quand allez-vous mettre fin à l'entente
nouveau projet client s'il est des
soutes à
merci
question nous avons très largement ces
dernières années réduit
les moyens de production utilisant des
énergies fossiles charbon gaz attendant
nous sommes en phase de réduction rapide
en partant d'une situation qui est
infiniment meilleures que celles de tous
nos grands concurrents
passaient un autre casting allemande
france qui complète
je ne sais pas vraiment ce qu'il faut
parce que les chiffres sont accablants
edf n'a pas compris qu'on était dans une
situation d'urgence climatique et que
précisément on avait dix à quinze ans
pour agir et qu'il fallait laisser les
énergies fossiles dans le sol et en
priorité le char levant
qu'en pense le principal actionnaire
d'edf à savoir l'état français
quelques jours plus tard industriels
financiers experts se retrouve à
l'unesco pour un mini-sommet la business
and climate week
[Musique]
plusieurs membres du gouvernement se
sont déplacés
ségolène royal est là pour signer un
accord avec des industriels
[Musique]
la ministre de l'ecologie dispose d'une
représentante au conseil
d'administration d'edf elle affiche
pourtant un discours très déterminés sur
le charbon que deux exigences première
exigence c'est dire maintenant on arrête
d'investir dans charbon et on investit
moon dans le tout ce qui toutes les
marges de manoeuvre dans le renouvelable
et deuxièmement pour les investissements
pour on pose une exigence sur la
propreté maximale des technologies du
charbon c'est une pression que vous
faites parce que pour l'instant c'est
pas ça pas été décidé comme ça en tout
cas et l'administration m et ce sera la
position du représentant qui met istin
l'environnement
en réalité le gouvernement peine à
imposer cette exigence de propreté même
dans les entreprises dont l'état est
l'actionnaire principal
devant l'unesco des militants écolos
manifeste pour rappeler que des f n'est
pas un cas isolé
son principal concurrent français angie
l'ex udf suez pour le même encore plus
de charbon malgré une communication très
verte
vous avez remarqué comme petit à petit
le monde change
le noir est maintenant presque vert
[Musique]
et gdf suez et maintenant mais ni car le
monde change
toutes nos énergies
le monde de angie c'est aussi 30
centrales à charbon l'une d'entre elles
est au coeur d'un scandale
environnemental à 100 kilomètres de la
frontière française
[Musique]
vado ligure et sur la riviera italienne
c'est pas sa plage et sa centrale à
charbon
[Musique]
construite dans les années 70 elle
appartient à une entreprise italienne
tirreno power détenue à 50% par l'ex gdf
suez
[Musique]
depuis un an elle est fermée sur
décision judiciaire
le motif cinglant figurent sur cet acte
d'accusation 10 astros en dan dah les
catastrophes environnementales
dans ce dossier explosif le procureur
vient d'inculper six cadres français et
belge de gdf certains pour homicide
involontaire
il s'appuie notamment sur cette étude
épidémiologique
selon laquelle la pollution aurait causé
la mort d'au moins 4 127 personnes entre
2000 et 2007
l'entreprise conteste l'étude et dans
les villages qui entoure la centrale la
sphère semble entendue la plupart des
décès inexpliqués lui sont imputées
reina rosso vite à quelques kilomètres
de la centrale
bonjour
bonjour poussins tu fais un bisou à ma
grand mère
bon voilà les photos
elle a perdu son père et deux de ses
frères nord de cancer comme le chanteur
a passé à commencer par papa le premier
ensuite un frère de 52 ans un autre de
64 ans sur la photo on dirait qu'il a 70
ou 80 ans mais il en a seulement 64
c'était un cancer oui un cancer nous les
soeurs nous sommes tout sous contrôle
médical pour un problème de thyroïde
d'utérus
et on gère la situation
les femmes comme d'habitude porte le
drapeau de la famille rey sont plus
fortes et plus tôt nasa qui est
impossible d'établir un lien certain
entre la centrale et les cancers
elle est vraiment belle s'est très tôt
merina et sa soeur n'ont aucun doute
le nombre de cas est si élevé pas
seulement dans ma famille mais en
général atta que selon moi ça ne peut
venir que de la pollution marine
pour répondre aux accusations la société
qui gère la centrale a multiplié les
campagnes de contrôle communications et
les journées portes ouvertes
pour nous la maîtrise des rejets
polluants c'est ce qu'il ya de plus
important les visiteurs vont voir que le
moniteur de contrôle des émissions est
au centre de la salle de commande
espérons qu'ils ressortent avec la
condition ils peuvent croire en tirreno
power
mais la justice italienne suspecte toute
une série de négligences et
d'engagements non tenus
elle s'appuie sur des écoutes
téléphoniques réalisées par les
carabinieri italiens ne nous y sommes
procurés
dans un premier extrait un cadre de
l'entreprise et le directeur de la
centrale pasquale délia évoque
l'installation d'un faux détecteur de
pollution
agence nous impose de mettre un capteur
sur la cheminée un de plus
mais nous avons pris la décision de ne
pas le faire nous avons choisi un
capteur sur la cheminée disons virtuelle
dans une autre écoute le directeur
regrette le sous investissement dans la
centrale
[Musique]
le directeur général devrait en parler
aux actionnaires parce qu'il y à des
interventions minima à la sphère
minimale nous parlons d'une dizaine de
millions d'euros pour réduire nos
émissions
un banquier de l'entreprise évoque enfin
une entrevue avec le haut dirigeant de
gdf suez l'an dernier à paris parmi
lesquels affirme-t-il isabelle kocher
actuel numéro deux de l'énergie
nous lieu vendredi regardez kocher vous
avez récolté 700 millions d'euros de
dividendes s'il n'avait pas été versée
ils auraient pu être utilisés pour pour
nous faire une centrale en or massif
isabelle kocher n'a pas souhaité
répondre à notre demande d'interview
mais elle conteste le récit du banquier
au siège du groupe à la défense la
direction d' angie un département
responsabilité environnementale
c'est sa responsable qui a été mandaté
par le groupe pour nous recevoir
sa ligne de défense les émissions de la
centrale n'ont jamais dépassé les seuils
fixés en italie nous avons toujours
respecté la réglementation que ce soit
la réglementation les lois en général la
réglementation environnementale que ce
soit en italie ou ailleurs
et sur le cas particulier de cette
centrale vado ligure et je ne peux pas
vous donner plus d'éléments puisqu'il ya
un processus en cours il ya une décision
de justice qui est attendue donc je ne
peux pas m'exprimer davantage sur ce
point là
la mise en examen ouvre la voie à un
procès
à vado ligure et riner et sa soeur en
attendent beaucoup
à mais non la rotonde et un je veux que
pour une fois quelqu'un paye que les
responsables payent ils les dirigeants
tous ceux qui ont été de connivence
qu'ils étaient d'accord qui ont donné
des permis mais je veux qu'ils changent
leur façon de produire de l'énergie
charbon ça suffit le charbon
au pape
un voeu pieux si en europe les normes
environnementales ou la justice incite
les entreprises à fermer leurs centrales
à charbon ce combustible polluant a le
vent en poupe dans les pays en forte
croissance
c'est même un investissement attractif
pour les plus grandes institutions
financières parmi lesquels nos banques
françaises
bnp paribas crédit agricole société
générale crédit mutuel ou encore la bpce
la banque populaire tout en déplacement
dans le charbon
[Musique]
est l'un des pays de prédilection
c'est l'inde
bnp paribas investi 327 millions d'euros
en 2008 dans l'ouest du pays à moudre à
[Applaudissements]
dans une centrale très controversé
boudra c'est l'un des plus grands sites
thermique au monde
8750 mégawatt produit par deux centrales
à charbon géante et voici la centrale
financé par bnp paribas
tous les ans plusieurs milliers de
pêcheurs s'installe entre les cheminées
et la mer
[Musique]
la famille d'ismael vient d'arriver pour
le début de la saison
rassemblés autour de son patriarche
alors comment et la mer aujourd'hui
tu as vu des bateaux partir pêcher
seulement quelques-uns la majorité va
partir demain je pense
la famille a vu ses conditions de vie se
dégrader depuis la construction de la
centrale
lorsqu'ils ont construit leurs centrales
ça a tout détruit ils ont détruit une
route que l'on utilisait est recouvert
une source elle était très abondante et
maintenant l'eau est salée est imbuvable
avant je fais ch et 4000 kilos de
poissons en huit mois maintenant on
empêche trois fois moment sans tabou
bonjour comment ça va bonjour pour se
défendre six semaines a monté une
association avec plusieurs autres
pêcheurs et bien mais là un expert
reconnu en inde allez ensuite soumis à
douta ingénieur en environnement
la centrale compte de l'eau de mer puis
la rejette dans ce chenal reliés à l'eau
c'est en chine et à dubaï n'a pas eu
besoin de beaucoup de moyens pour en
mesurer les conséquences
un simple thermomètre
la température de l'eau et de 35,2 35,4
degrés alors que dans la mer elle est
entre 29 et 30
degrés de plus ici et on sait que
n'importe quelle espèce marine habitués
à des températures de 29 ou 30 degrés
vie très difficilement dans 5 degrés de
plus
l'ingénieur suspecte aussi l'entreprise
de rejeter des produits chimiques
without cameco la une des chaînes les
ans les polluants il n'y aurait pas
cette mousse
quand on remet l'eau de mer normalement
on ne voit pas ce genre de mousse donc
c'est un indicateur de la présence de
produits chimiques
en 2011 ils prélèvent des échantillons
et une simple analyse en laboratoire lui
permet d'identifier un taux faible
d'oxygène dans l'eau un marqueur connu
de la présence de polluants
il retranscrit ses analyses dans ce
rapport intitulé le vrai coût de
l'énergie
une ong le finance pour aller le
présenter à la banque mondiale à
washington l'un des principaux
investisseurs dans la centrale avec la
bnp et la banque mondiale valide la
plupart de ses conclusions
quatre ans plus tard soumis à va le
constater
peu de choses ont changé
devant la centrale il mesure les
émissions de particules fines
ça va prendre 21 une seconde là on est
bien au dessus des limites légales là
aussi il n'y a que pour les particules
de 10 microns qu'on ne dépasse que
légèrement et les villageois sont
exposés à ces particules 365 jours par
an
derrière la centrale sous le pont
roulant utilisé pour transporter le
charbon
nous découvrons une étendue noir de
poussière
[Musique]
le pont roulant n'est pas hermétique et
avec la quantité de charbon qui tombent
ici chaque jour c'est aussi toxique que
de vivre près d'une mine
soumia tombe sur ces deux ouvriers que
l'on croirait sorti d'un roman de zola
il travaille et d'hommes ici depuis
quatre mois
qu'elle vous ressentez quoi quand vous
vous réveillez on peine à dormir la
poussière rentrer dans nos oreilles de
nos yeux la buissière de charbon oui oui
c'est ça et vous tous c'est alors oui on
tousse tout le temps on est souvent
malades
quel type de maladie on ne sait pas
vraiment mais c'est très inconfortable
la poussière pénètre nos corps
[Musique]
me le groupe indien qui gère la centrale
ils actionnaires bnp paribas ont accepté
de répondre à nos questions
mais souvient a pu rencontrer plusieurs
cadres de la banque française à paris en
avril dernier
quand je les ai vus ils m'ont dit qu'ils
n'avaient pas conscience de ce qui s'est
passé ici alors que tout le monde sait
que la réglementation est appliquée -
fermement ici en inde qu'il y a des
lacunes dans la loi il aurait dû poser
la question est ce que votre pont
roulant et bien hermétique est ce qu'il
y a des villages proches de la centrale
ces questions n'ont pas été posées car
il était intéressé par le profil le
profit avant toute chose medac sociaux
la mer est écrite
aujourd'hui le charbon couvre 40% des
besoins en énergie de la planète
mais la mobilisation commence à produire
des effets
ces derniers mois de grands groupes
comme total axa ou encore le crédit
agricole ont annoncé la fin de leur
investissement dans ce combustible
la fin peut-être les charbons roi
certains